hello everyone I'm briefly interrupting
the capablanca saga to bring you very
important news from the chest world now
you all remember Booker T we already saw
a very nice game by him on this channel
here he faces another international
master from India Dinesh Sharma it's
from the 17th Delhi international chess
tournament and as of today goo coach D
is the youngest Grand Master in the
world he missed his chance to become the
youngest ever Grandmaster in the world
by 12 days so the record is still held
by Sarah Kerrigan but even so the being
the youngest master in the world today a
huge accomplishment so like I said this
is from round 9 the tournament is still
going on I believe round 10 is being
played today and he already faced four
grandmasters in this tournament without
a single loss so without further ado
let's check out the game it's um it's
really really a modern masterpiece is
just a beautiful game to check out so I
do hope you enjoy it now we have efore
by guca we have e 6 the fringe defence
someone already joked in the comments
that he should get extra norms for for
such an accomplishment against the
French defense d4 d5 Knight d2 the
tariff variation of the French brush up
to e7 and now II 5 advancing the pawn
and c5 the usual response when a white
advances the e pawn in the French c3
strengthening the center we have knight
c6 and Bishop to d3 see capture C
captures and Queen to b6 pressuring the
d4 pawn but not really Knight d2 f3 and
now comes Knight to h6 if some of you
are actually wondering you cannot
capture the d4 pawn because after
captures captures Bishop b5 check and
black loses the Queen so that's not
happening
after Knight d2 f3 we have nice - h6 and
now comes from 92 Lucas also is ready to
Castle and here we have a couple of
moves that are familiar in this position
f5 has been played here Knight to f5 has
been played here here f6 is played and
this is a new move that was not played
in this position but since we have a
captures on f6 it's pretty much the same
as if black played f5 and white captures
on f6 on Poisson so we have
captures and here there is one game in
the database were white captured on h6
and black wanted game but here Lucas
decides to keep the Bishop air heat
simple castles and he says okay black
castles I might then capture on h6 mess
up blacks King side and start started a
starter King side attack so nice to f7
black doesn't allow this and now you
could go as the d4 pawn now really is
attacked you could try something like
Bishop to e3 where black couldn't really
capture on b2 perhaps it would be too
dangerous
but guca mmediately starts with an
attack he goes night at four and
sacrifices the d4 pawn Knight character
son d4 and now comes knight to h5 and
okay attacking the bishop here tonight
captures on a3 with Czech Queen captures
on f3 and now comes Bishop to e5 you
don't want a long night captures here
but it's a hard to decide what to do if
you go something like a bishop to d4
which seems like a better choice maybe
Bishop to e3 will not come with an
attack on the Queen not really after
Bishop to e3
you still can't castle and if you if you
capture then you open up White's F file
it will be very dangerous if you castle
then you have this very nice queen g4
idea threatening checkmate not to
checkmate
as of now because the bishop is still
controlling it but there is a double
attack against the bishop on d4 if you
capture then it's checkmate if you don't
capture yeah I mean you can't move it
back if you if you move it somewhere
along these lines then the Queen is
under attack here you don't really have
a good good move you would have to go
something like Knight h6 attack the
Queen and then just give up and give up
the piece and slowly but surely you will
lose this game so okay dinners goes for
a different idea he goes bust up to e5
and now we have Bishop to e3 attacking
the Queen Queen back to d8 you don't
want to capture a pawn here that's I
mean here you are under attack you want
to the Queen to be able to help out with
the defense and now push up the c5
closing of this diagonal so the King is
now definitely unable to castle Bishop
to d7
we have rook F to e1 and now comes Queen
to c7 with Queen to g5 here black black
would still hold his own and would
still be in this game but after Queen to
c7 it's a bit of a different story
first rook to c1 now you're threatening
all sorts of discoveries as the rook is
aligned with the Queen on the C file and
you don't really gain anything by Bishop
H to check if this King h1 you now have
to move the bishop because g3 is a
threat after there should be five now
again Queen g4 a very dangerous idea
pressuring e6 preferring g7 and here
let's say you go for a queenside castle
you will get rush up to d4 now your
queen is under attack this is a huge
threat you cannot escape with a king
after Bishop c6 Queen captures an e6
check is coming and after King b8 and
now comes rope captures on e5 and the
black is falling apart you cannot really
capture because you lose the Queen again
so a very dangerous position instead of
capturing on h2 dinner decides to go
rook the c8 develop the piece and also
put pressure along the C file but again
queen g4 again pressuring the g7 pawn so
what do you do here we have g6 defending
and now it's a it's a very short
position but before I ask you to post
the video which I will first we do have
a couple of nice photos by David Lada at
there we have it it could be somewhere
around this position I do see the Queen
and g4 it's a bit a bit right so the
knight is not yet on h5 but still it's
it's around this position definitely
around the critical moment of the game
and also we have a very nice close-up of
young Lucas so there we have it I will
also put as usual some very nice links
to David wada Instagram Twitter and the
Facebook page so if you enjoy chess
photos you know he has a lot of
excellent photos do do follow him and do
check out some of his other work but
yeah after g6 feel free to pause the
video and try to find the idea Lucas
used here too well amongst other things
become the youngest Grand Master in the
world I will give you a couple seconds
as usual for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations you are now the
youngest Grand Master in the world is
just kidding you're not but still it's
it's a very nice move and for those of
you just want to enjoy the show
Knight g7 check and here's the problem
you can't go anywhere along
sorry along this diagonal so you can
either capture the night with the bishop
or run away King d8 if you go King d8
Knight captures on e6 check Forks the
king and the Queen you have to capture
it the bursar captures now comes Queen
captures and what do you play here again
Bishop to e7 a lot of threats here the
Queen is still aligned with the rook so
after Queen c6 let's say you want to
defend the d5 pawn and also offer to
trade Queens it doesn't work you get
Queen e7 checkmate and on the other hand
if you want to try something else let's
say we want to go rook e8 then you have
to give up the d5 pawn Queen captures
again you have to block Queen d7 and now
you get Queen capture skin captures and
now Bishop to b5 check this is deadly
King has to move now comes Bishop
captures rook captures and after a for
winning yet another Bishop whatever
black plays you will capture and then
you are up a whole rook and black is in
black is doomed so after 9 g7 Czech
dinner decided to capture the night with
Bishop captures and now comes the move
you really had to find if you found a g7
chair so if you haven't watched the
video again and try to find the
continuation to this attack for those of
you who were able to do it now really
congratulations you are truly an
excellent player and for those who just
want to enjoy the show rook captures on
e6 the problem is you still can't move
anywhere other than the 8th and this
doesn't work for for similar reasons so
if you capture it you have to face Queen
captures and then after King to d8 it's
simply lost Bishop e7 check the rook now
attacks the Queen after Queen captures
on e7 you will get rook captures here
with the checkmate or if you don't want
to capture the bishop if you simply move
the King then you get the bishop the b5
check again Queen has the block and then
we have this very nice double Bishop
checkmate so after rook captures on e6
you have to move the King even though
you don't want to King d8 was played but
now comes Bishop to e7 check King to e8
and now we have Bishop to d6 check
checking the King but also attacking the
Queen here and again you can capture due
to the same reasons King today I
displayed and now Bishop captures on c7
grabs the
Queen rook captures on c7 with rook
captures on c7 King captures on c7 and
okay or a rock is still pinned here but
simply Queen to f4 check and it was in
this position that international master
dina sharma resigned the game and a very
nice victory for young [ __ ] HD once the
King moves always taking c8 then you can
unpin you can go rocky seven and white
is just up too much material there is no
point in continuing this game yeah
really a wonderful game and a wonderful
accomplishment for young [ __ ] OD who is
now after winning his third the Grand
Master norm we already said only only 12
days behind of Sergei character in the
record but still you know grandmasters
are becoming younger and younger there
are a lot more new players a lot more
rating in the system you know I'm sure
it will be it will be the records will
be broken more and more and the you know
the age bar for becoming a grandmaster
will go lower and lower and lower but
that's a you know an idea a topic for a
different video and you know even a huge
discussion yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Tyler Stabler ski Fred Ackerman
look at Ibaka rocker my knee and pewter
reaching out for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot
I really appreciate it as usual you can
check through my previous videos your
thing called for watching and I will see
you soon we're gonna check up on Tata
Steel and also continuing the capablanca
saga the 1911 son Sebastian tournament
thank you all and I will see you soon